this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
treatment options for breast cancer
include surgery
chemotherapy
radiation therapy
hormone therapy
and targeted therapy
there are several surgical options
depending on the severity of the cancer
a lumpectomy removes the tumor
and a clear margin of surrounding tissue
this procedure is always followed by
radiation therapy treatment to kill
unseen cancer cells
mastectomies involve removing the entire
breast
after a mastectomy a woman has the
option to have reconstructive surgery
where a new breast is created using
implants
or skin flaps
in some cases the surgeon is able to
preserve the nipple
sentinel lymph node removal is typically
performed in addition to lumpectomies
and mastectomies
if there's no clinical evidence that
cancer has spread to the lymph nodes
here your surgeon will remove one or
more of the first lymph nodes draining
the breast and check it for the presence
of cancer cells
if these nodes are clean it is not
necessary to remove more lymph nodes
however if cancer has spread to these
lymph nodes
a complete axillary lymph node
dissection or removal of most or all of
the lymph nodes in the armpit area may
be recommended
chemotherapy is a treatment that uses
drugs to stop the growth of cancer cells
by either killing them or inhibiting
their cell division
once the drugs enter the bloodstream
they can travel and reach cancer cells
throughout the body
radiation therapy is performed following
surgery or in combination with
chemotherapy
it uses high energy radiation beams or
particles to kill the remaining cancer
cells or keep them from growing
the main types of radiation therapy are
external beam radiation
internal radiation
also known as brachytherapy
and intraoperative radiation
in external beam radiation such as
intensity modulated radiation therapy or
imrt a machine called a linear
accelerator delivers radiation beams
from outside of the body to the cancer
it treats the breast from different
angles while precisely targeting the
tumor
internal radiation therapy can be used
after a lumpectomy or for women with
early stage cancer
it treats cancer from inside the breast
using hollow applicator tubes with a
radiation source passed through them
in intraoperative radiation therapy
radiation is delivered during a breast
sparing surgery such as a lumpectomy
after the tumor is removed
the radiation source may be an external
beam that comes from a linear
accelerator
or the radiation may be applied
internally by inserting the spherical
applicator from a mobile x-ray device
into the breast
in either case the radiation is limited
to just the tissue that surrounded the
tumor most breast cancers are hormone
receptor positive which means they need
hormones in order to grow and spread
hormone therapy works by blocking the
cancer cells from receiving the natural
hormones that they need
tests on the tumor show if it has these
hormone receptors
targeted therapy uses specially designed
drugs such as monoclonal antibodies that
act on specific molecules inside or
outside of cancer cells
tests on the tumor samples can tell
whether they have target molecules for
these drugs
for example herceptin is an antibody
drug that targets and slows the growth
of her2 positive tumors
these tumors have a high amount of her2
receptors which are the target molecules
for the drug